out of
all the things you've done you've also
climbed mount kilimanjaro
is this true it's true
uh what do you uh
why and how and what do you take from
that experience
i guess the back story is relevant
because
that uh in that moment it was the
darkest time in my life i was
ending the 13-year marriage i was
leaving my religion i sold braintree and
i was coming
battling depression where i was just at
the end
and i got invited to go to
tanzania as part of a group that was
raising money to build clean water wells
and i had made some money from braintree
and so i was able to
donate 25 000 and it was the first time
i had ever had money to donate
outside of paying tithing at my religion
it was such a phenomenal experience
to to contribute something meaningful to
someone else
in that form and as part of this process
we were going to climb the mountain and
so
we went there and we saw the clean water
whales we were building we spoke to the
the people there and it was very
energizing and then we climbed
kilimanjaro
and i came down with
a stomach flu on on day three
and i also had altitude sickness but i
became so sick that on day four
we were summoned on day five i came into
the camp base camp at 15 000 feet uh
just you know going to the bathroom on
myself and like falling all over it
it was just i was just a disaster uh i
was so sick so stomach flu
and altitude sickness yeah and i just
was
destroyed uh from the situation
and plus psychologically one of the
lowest points
yeah and i think that was probably a big
contributor i was i was just smoked as a
human
just absolutely done and i had three
young children and so i was trying to
reconcile like
this is not a whether whether i live or
not is not my decision
by itself i'm now intertwined with these
three little
people and i have an obligation whether
i like it or not
i need to be there and so it did it felt
like i was just stuck in a straight
jacket
and i had to decide whether i was going
to
summit the next day with the team
and it was a difficult decision because
once you start hiking there's no way to
get off the mountain
and midnight came and our guide came in
and he said where you at and i said
i think i'm okay i think i can try and
so we we went
and so from midnight
to i made it to the summit at 5 00 a.m
it was one of the most transformational
moments of my existence
and the mountain became
my problem it became everything that i
was struggling with and when i started
hiking it was
the pain got so ferocious uh that
it was kind of like this it became so
ferocious that
um i turned my music to
eminem and it was you know eminem was is
the he was the
only person in existence that spoke to
my soul
and it was something about you know his
anger and his
vibrancy and his multi-bench way he's
the only person
who i could turn on and i could say ah
like i feel some relief
i turned i turned on eminem and um i
made it to the summit
uh after five hours uh but just just a
hundred yards from the top
i was with my guide ike and i started
getting very
dizzy and i was i felt like i was gonna
fall backwards off this this cliff area
we were on i was like this is dangerous
and uh he said look brian i i know where
you're at
i know where you're at and i can tell
you you've got it in you
so i want you to look up take a step
take a breath and look up take a breath
and take a step
and i did and i made it and so
i got there and i just i sat down with
him at the top i just cried like a baby
broke down did just i just lost it and
uh
so you know he'd let me do my thing and
then we pulled out the
pulse oximeter and he measured my blood
oxygen levels and it's like it was like
50 something percent and it was danger
zone so he so he looked at it and i
think he was like really alarmed
i was in this situation and so uh
he said we can't get a helicopter here
and we can't get you emergency evacuated
you've got to go down you've got to hike
down to 15 000 feet to get base camp
and so he we went down the mountain
i got back down to base camp and um
again that was pretty difficult and then
they put me on a stretcher this metal
stretcher with this one will
and a team of six people wheeled me down
the mountain
and it was it was pretty torturous i'm
very appreciative they did also the
trail was very bumpy so they'd go over
these big rocks and so my head would
just slam
against this metal thing for hours and
so i just felt awful plus i'd get my
head slammed every couple seconds
yeah so the whole experience uh was
really a life-changing moment and that's
it that was the demarcation of me
basically
building your life of basically i said
i'm going to
reconstruct brian my
my understanding of reality my
existential realities what i want to go
after
and i try i mean as much as that's
possible as a human but that's when
i set out to rebuild everything
was it the struggle of that i mean
there's also just like the romantic
poetic it's a freaking mountain
he's a man in in pain psychological and
and physical
struggling up a mountain but it's just
struggle
just uh in the in the face of
just pushing through in the face of
hardship or nature
too something much bigger than you
is that was that the thing that just
clicked for me it felt like i was just
locked in with reality
and it was a death match
it was in that moment one of us is gonna
die so you were pondering death
yeah like not surviving yeah and and it
was and that was the moment
and it was uh the summit to me was
i i'm gonna come out on top and i can do
this and
giving in was it's like i'm just done
and so it did i locked in and that's why
yeah mountains are magical to me
i didn't expect that i didn't design
that i didn't know that was going to be
the case
i and not it would not have been
something i would have anticipated
but you are not the same man afterwards
you